Yay!
Hello, hello everybody!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Okay guys, you see there's some new stuff on the screen.
And I hear myself... oh no, okay I fixed it.
Okay, I don't hear myself anymore.
Okay...
Hello everybody!
I'm so excited to show you guys all these things on my screen.
You're like, oh my god, it looks so fancy!
So I'm gonna post this right now.
So, what is this fancy thing that's going on on the screen at the moment?
So here I post this.
Let me pin this real quick.
So basically, I downloaded this from...
I was like following this creator that does like widgets for stream stuff.
I've always wanted to use it.
It's like a streamer task list widget.
And then all you have to do...
I don't know if it doesn't pop up.
Okay, someone tried it.
Okay, it didn't work.
I'm just gonna try it again.
I'm sorry.
I saw someone already tried it.
And nothing popped up.
Okay, I didn't know.
Guys, give me a sec.
Let me figure this out.
I thought that was how you do it!
Okay, task command.
Permission.
It says viewers!
Why is it not viewing?
I was able to put stuff on.
I don't know about you guys.
Okay, did I like mess it up?
Okay, uh...
Give me a sec.
I didn't like...
Actually...
Yeah!
It says add!
Add news task to the list.
Yeah!
Exclamation point add!
What the fuck?
Why is it not working?
I was able to!
Okay, watch this.
Add...
Um...
Fix the to-do list.
Am I...
Am I even...
Am I not on anonymous mode?
Am I on anonymous mode right now?
Give me a sec, guys.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I forgot I'm on anonymous mode on Twitch.
So when I'm on anonymous mode on Twitch, I can't do anything.
Okay.
Oh no.
Give me a sec.
I can't even load Twitch at the moment.
Oh, it's all over.
It's over already.
I was... It was so cool too!
I was like, oh my god.
This is so cool.
I can like add stuff.
Oh wait, is this why?
Wait, I think I know why it doesn't work.
Give me a sec.
Oh!
It was the wrong command.
Okay, I fixed it.
Alright, now it should work.
I figured it out.
I gave you guys the wrong command.
There we go!
What do you mean it's over?
I can delete...
I can literally delete commands.
Guys, please!
This is supposed... We're supposed to be working together!
Chat!
We are supposed to be working together, chat.
Stop!
I will delete your commands!
Wait, no!
Mods can delete commands!
Mods, I'm so sorry.
I know.
Okay, I've started paying.
I'm not paying the mods though.
You can't be like they're doing it for free.
Because I can finally afford to pay the mods.
So like...
Mods, why?
Okay, alright.
Alright.
Mods, you're getting paid now!
So, all you have to do is is the command to delete other people's...
The command to delete other people's shitty tasks that are not relevant is delete.
So, it's exclamation point...
Wait, let me read the...
Let me read the guidelines.
Okay, it's exclamation point, delete, and then you... I swear to god!
And then like delete the username.
All you have to do is just exclamation point, delete, and then you delete whoever's username has like the shitty task that is not relevant.
You just do...
delete the username's task.
So...
Not enough for...
What do you mean?
Look at all my tasks!
Look at all the fucking chat's to-do list!
There's...
This is not...
This is your to-do list, guys.
This is not my to-do list.
If you're gonna...
I'm gonna put...
Twitch, this is...
Jinger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is your to-do list.
I have my list on my left side.
My list is on the left side.
Your list is on the right side.
And also, also, if you guys are like...
We can also ban people.
If we ban people on Twitch, then like all the tasks get removed instantly.
So like there's also that option.
So...
If it's easier.
30 minutes slow-mo.
Okay, guys.
Maybe...
Not 30...
Okay, this is...
There's a lot of tasks coming in.
109 chat!
Anyway...
I was really excited to try this new widget out.
It's from...
Who is it?
Sayonani?
Because I've been like following her stuff.
Like the stuff she develops.
On like widget...
For streamer widget.
But it only works on Twitch.
I mean I could invite...
I wonder if I could invite stream elements...
I was thinking about inviting stream elements into YouTube.
Because it's like a stream elements widget.
But then I was like I didn't want to clutter up my own chat.
Like on the YouTube chat.
So like...
I figured it's like...
It was like also partially inspired by Ame.
Like remember her...
Her music bot?
Where like she used to...
When she used to do like those like...
Those like streams where you can listen to music.
By suggesting music on Twitch.
And stuff like that.
So it like inspired me to do something similar.
To separate...
Separate like you know the task list on Twitch.
So it doesn't clutter up the...
Yeah, Bubba bot.
Yeah.
So it doesn't clutter up...
The YouTube chat.
So that's why I decided to...
Cause like I think you can invite stream elements to YouTube chat.
And it'll do the same thing.
But I figured like okay I don't want my chat to just be filled...
With fucking stupid things that are not...
Relevant to the task.
Cause I know you guys were gonna troll with that.
I...
I knew you guys were gonna troll...
With a fucking command list.
So I figured...
I'm gonna separate this to...
The Twitch chat.
So you can suggest stuff over there.
And my YouTube chat.
At least people can still be...
Chatting on the YouTube chat.
But I think it's so cool though.
Isn't it cool?
So like I can do like... I can complete my task too.
Like I thought it was so cool.
Um...
That like you know...
Like we can like work in real time.
Like my stuff on the left side.
Your stuff on the right side.
Two out of 154.
You guys are like 1% complete.
Let's race guys.
Let's see who can get their stuff done first.
Let's see who has like...
A higher percentage...
Of completing their task guys.
Oh my god.
I wonder who will win.
Oh wow.
Oh Ben.
We were set up.
You guys did this to yourself.
Hey guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know us so well.
What's the difference between done and complete?
It's the same thing.
So you can use done or complete.
It's people who like you know...
Want to type...
Want a shorter word.
You just do exclamation point.
Done and I hope you remember what you wrote.
Like I hope...
I hope you remember what you fucking wrote guys.
I wonder if there's like another thing you can type.
Let me double check.
Let's see.
Settings.
Commands.
To do complete.
Complete and done are the same thing.
So I hope you guys remember.
Cause I don't.
I think if you do...
Oh you do delete.
Maybe if you do delete.
And then your username.
I think it's like delete.
And then your username on Twitch.
It deletes all the tasks.
For your entire...
Like all the tasks that you put on there.
I think.
Guys I'm learning this as I go.
Oh yeah yeah yeah.
Oh no this is mod only.
Nevermind only mods can do that.
So like I hope you remember.
Nevermind.
It says mod only commands.
JK.
You guys better remember what you wrote.
Okay.
Mod you're only deleting the ones.
That are useless.
That are obviously trolls.
So yeah.
I mean if you don't remember.
Then you're failing the rest of the dragoons.
Cause you're like.
Cause technically.
I'm winning.
The moment I finish one of my tasks.
I basically win the race.
Because I don't know.
7 out of 184.
I don't know guys.
I don't fucking know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
By racing against Doki answering DMs.
We can literally never lose.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway.
You know I'm giving you guys a head start.
Cause I want to do a little Zatatan.
Last week was a full on Tekken week.
Plus Sunday.
And we didn't really have a time.
To actually like hang out.
And chat.
Like it was just Tekken Tekken Tekken Tekken.
And uh.
Honestly I'm like super.
Oh my gosh.
I was like what is that sound?
I don't think you guys hear it.
But it was like oh it's the task complete sound.
So every time you guys complete a task.
There's like a little pencil sound effect.
And like it catches me off guard.
I was like.
Is that my music?
Like.
Uh.
But yes.
The Tekken Arc.
Uh.
And it was like.
Oh my gosh.
I'm like.
I'm like so tired.
From the time.
I was like.
I think like right after the tournament.
I was like oh my gosh I was so tired.
And like mentally exhausted.
Cause my social battery was like.
Gone basically.
Cause it was like uh.
With hanging out with like.
Uh.
Five.
Five people.
And then like for six plus hours.
Almost every day.
So my social battery.
As an introvert.
My social battery.
Is like depleted now.
I think like yesterday.
I think I slept.
Yesterday.
I basically slept like.
I think like.
Oh my gosh.
I slept the whole day.
I like woke up.
I woke up.
And then uh.
And then like um.
And then I think I was only awake for like.
Two to three hours.
And then I went back to sleep.
I was so tired.
I was like oh my gosh I gotta get work done.
I'm so behind because of Tekken.
And then so I started getting work done.
And then I think like two to three hours.
I went back to sleep.
And then I woke up at 11pm.
I woke up at 11pm.
And I was like.
Oh fuck I have so much work to do.
And then I got distracted.
And only did one hour of work.
And I actually got back to work.
At like 3am.
And started you know.
That's why I posted my schedule at like 4 in the morning.
Because you know.
I've been awake for.
I've only been awake for like 1% of the day.
So I managed to get my schedule done.
At 4 in the morning.
Um.
But I'm very behind.
I am very very.
Very behind.
I did a lot of things at the moment.
Because of Tekken.
And uh.
And just like burying myself with training for Tekken.
But it was a great time.
Honestly I'm so happy.
I said yes to doing the Sajam Slam.
It was a great experience.
And I made so many new friends.
I really love team Brawl Pro.
They were great to hang out with.
And honestly like.
Um.
Never expected to win first place.
That's for sure.
The biggest upset in history.
When I beat SK.
No one.
Like I think like only.
Like 5% believed in me.
In the Sajam.
Because there was like a betting pool.
There was a betting pool apparently.
During like the me vs SK match.
And it was like 300k.
Versus 1.5 million.
Hahahaha.
I was like.
I was literally.
It was like a David vs Goliath situation.
Nobody expected me to win.
Hahahaha.
It was actually.
Fucking crazy.
Hahahaha.
And um.
I'm really happy that.
I honestly never expected to win first.
I was like oh man.
I know my team was really really good.
In general.
Because you know this was like the same team in the first Sajam Slam.
And we literally have Jack Jesus.
Who like only lost one game.
In the entire Sajam Slam.
Um.
And uh.
I honestly.
I expected second.
But not first.
Because I feel like first heavily relied on me.
Winning at least one game.
Hahahaha.
Like.
That's what first was.
Like I just literally needed to win one game.
And I was like.
Oh I don't know about this.
Hahahaha.
I was like.
I don't know.
It's SK.
Hahahaha.
I don't think even my team.
Expected me to win that one game.
I think my team was just like.
Okay.
Let's just make sure she's not sad.
When she loses.
Hahahaha.
I feel like they were just like.
Let's just make sure she's not sad.
And that she's hap...
And that she's having a good time.
Hahahaha.
Uh.
Yeah nobody expected it.
But it was so.
Uh.
It was just insane that that happened.
I just realized my lure is like.
Not.
Sorry.
My lure is not showing up.
Because it's getting covered.
Let me put that here.
Anyway.
Insane experience.
I told Sajem.
That like.
Apparently the next Sajem slam is going to be Street Fighter.
And I hope I get invited.
To the Street Fighter one.
Because I honestly had a great time.
And then like a lot of the.
Team Brawl Pro wants to run it back again.
For the next Sajem slam.
So uh.
Yeah it's for Street Fighter 6.
So I honestly hope.
I hope I get invited for the next one.
And be also be placed back in Team Brawl Pro.
I don't know.
Like I don't feel like.
Oh why don't you want to be in a new team.
I just really like.
Team Brawl Pro.
It's just vibes.
You know.
I feel like.
If I was in any other team.
The chemistry would not be the same.
I don't know.
I just feel like it wouldn't be as fun.
If it was.
Like with any other.
Like combination.
I feel like it was just the perfect.
I feel like the team was just the perfect combination.
And I hope.
I asked Sajem.
I was like oh.
If possible.
I told him if possible.
I would love to be invited again.
For the next Sajem Slam.
So I hope I get in.
I hope I get into the next one.
Because it was definitely really really really fun.
Apparently.
I converted a lot of non-Vtuber fans.
Into watching me now.
Because I was so fucking ridiculous.
Because I was.
I was unfiltered as fuck.
And I'm sorry.
That this is the first stream you're coming to.
Where I'm like a bit more chill right now.
Because I am so behind.
On a lot of things.
If you're expecting.
More of what I was like.
During the Tekken Arc today.
I am so sorry.
I am so busy.
I am so.
I am so behind.
So like originally I wasn't gonna stream today.
Um.
I wasn't going to stream today.
Because of how busy I was.
But then I was like.
Man I haven't had time to actually.
You know.
Talk to you guys.
And hang out with my chat.
Because when I do like collabs.
I know like a lot of people who are used to watching like Fleshies.
Um.
You know.
They do like push to talk.
Where they would like you know talk to the group.
And then like talk to the chat.
And do push to talk.
I.
I am just.
I am just fucking lazy as well.
Uh.
You have to stop.
But they are Fleshies.
They call me 2D.
Because I am not real.
So I can't call them Fleshies.
Anyway.
Um.
As I was saying, usually the only time I mute myself to talk to my chat is if there was intermission time.
Which there was during some moments in Tekken where we had to wait for our games.
And that's when I muted myself to talk to you guys.
But usually in collabs, I try to give full focus on talking to the people I'm hanging out with.
Oh, sorry.
I meant the meatbags.
Thank you for the 20 gifted shits!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you!
Sage, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
More distractions.
Doki, yippee!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Let's give you guys a head start.
You guys definitely need it.
All I'm saying is that you need the head start.
Because the moment I finish one task, this race is over.
Like, this race is so over.
Come on chat, we're already at 25%.
But guys, you can literally add more...
Like, some fucker can...
Like, several fuckers can literally just add more tasks for you guys and ruin your race.
This is rigged.
There's slow mode.
Slow mode is at you!
I'm actually helping you guys!
I don't know...
Anyway, I mean, the mod can easily put it back...
Mod, put the slow mode to 10 minutes.
Put the slow mode to 10 minutes, not 30 minutes.
Like, give them that, I guess.
Anyway, but yes.
It is like... Oh my god, it doesn't stop.
Oh my god, it just keeps going.
Haha...
Um, where was I?
Um, blah...
Oh yes, but yes.
A lot of new...
We have a lot of new viewers.
That came from Tekken.
Because of the shit I say when I open my mouth.
But yes, welcome!
Welcome, new Dragons!
Usually, you know.
We usually have other types of streams.
Not this...
But like I said, it was a nice one.
Today I wasn't supposed to be streaming because of how behind I was on like everything like in life.
So I figured you know what let's just you know be able to let's just like stream our work right now.
Well I won't be showing you guys what the fuck I'm working on but like you know be able to stream for you guys.
Talk to you guys while we're working as well and also make you guys be productive as well.
So yeah and I always wanted to try this widget out like this.
I feel like it's nice because we can all just like be productive together.
And like all both of us me and that one dragoon.
Me and my one dragoon and his like 2000 bots accounts.
Work together on finishing stuff up.
Oh Tima thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on the tournament Doki.
You're awesome.
New fan here.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm glad you guys really enjoyed the tournament arc.
So like what else?
Oh yes as you can see this week is also pretty fucking packed.
I got invited to... you guys can see there's also an Apex tournament that's happening on the same day.
As WrestleLand.
As WrestleTuber.
So like I got invited to a VTuber.
What?
It says VTuber but then there's like non-VTubers in there.
There's like maybe like I think like two or three non-VTubers in there.
But anyway there is like a VTuber like Apex Invitational.
That's mostly NA.
And then like usually like I haven't really participated.
I don't know if you noticed.
But in the past I've never really been invited to like VTuber Invitationals in like NA parts of the world.
So I've... because like I've been invited to like more I guess like pro tournaments.
Like pro tournaments with like you know NA pros and stuff like that.
But not like VTuber Apex Invitational.
So I figured like... and I looked at the list.
I was like oh hey there's like some...
people here that are like you know well-known in the like Apex VTuber...
I think it's also because there's not a lot of like well-known Apex VTuber...
VTuber streamers in general.
I mean to be fair I'm barely an Apex VTuber streamer.
I'm barely one as well.
Like I'm just variety now.
So like I figured like they invited me.
But then I saw that it's sort of like...
Like when they invited me I couldn't tell them why.
Like I was just like oh I don't know guys.
Like I couldn't say like WrestleTuber because it wasn't announced yet.
So then I was like oh it's sort of conflicts with WrestleTuber because like my thing starts at 4.
And like I can't move the date and time because like there's a lot of people participating.
So then like the organizer was like oh we'll move our tournament.
And I felt bad because they moved the tournament for me.
So like they moved the time for it like an hour earlier for me.
So then I was like oh okay.
I was like oh okay that's really sweet okay.
So then I was like alright yeah I can do it.
As long as I have like time to...
As long as like...
Because I was like oh by the time it ends I have to...
I have to like do the WrestleTuber because originally they said it was going to end at 4.
And I was like oh I can't.
I can't do that.
I literally have to do something at 4.
And it's like this whole event that I'm organizing.
I couldn't say what event it was.
So then they were like oh we'll do it.
We'll have the tournament like an hour earlier.
Like and I was like oh okay.
And then because they you know they said they'll have the tournament an hour earlier.
I was like oh yeah okay I'll join.
Like because then like they moved the tournament.
So I was just like oh fuck.
Yeah I'll join.
And so and like I felt like I never really had a chance to join.
And like I said like all the other Apex Youtuber invitational stuff.
I've never really been like invited to it like as a captain.
I think like the last Vtuber invitational that happened.
I was like someone got invited and then they invited me to be on their team.
But then like the captain had to drop out at the last minute due to scheduling thing.
But then I didn't realize.
So I thought I was going to be part of it.
But then like because they dropped out.
The team like I think it was like a miscommunication thing.
Because they're like oh because it was supposed to be like we find a replacement for the captain.
But then like it was a miscommunication that they ended up giving the spot the team spot to a different team.
So then like I couldn't join.
So it was like I was really sad about that.
So like I've never had a chance to ever do a Vtuber invitational for Apex in like NA.
And I was like okay.
Like I like I when I first got invited.
I got that like the invite.
I was like really happy.
Because I've never been invited before as a captain.
So you know and I was like oh I'm sad.
So I was super super happy that like like I got invited to like to like one with like all the known like Apex Vtubers.
Like not just NA.
It's also EU.
Because I know like there's like.
Like I mean I had got RPR in it.
So it's not just NA.
But there's like but like you know like English.
I guess like English speaking.
English speaking Apex Vtubers.
I feel like that's the better term for it.
Apex.
Sorry.
English speaking Apex Vtubers.
So I'm really happy.
Anyway I dragged RPR and ditto to it.
We have our first.
Scrim tomorrow.
Apparently we've been having scrims for a while.
But like I was literally so busy.
I couldn't join any of the scrims.
So like and there's like cash prizes for the scrims.
So I think I mean it's like $150.
If we win I think.
Divide by three people.
So like you know $50 each.
If we win the first.
If we win the scrim.
But yes Wednesday is the.
Tomorrow is the first scrim.
I also got invited.
You guys can see.
I got invited to the.
To a.
Billy Billy.
Arc server.
Billy Billy Vtuber arc server.
But I'll be streaming it on YouTube.
Because I don't have a Billy Billy account yet.
Hiro invited me to it.
She asked me I wanted to check it out.
And there's gonna be like other.
Like Vtubers.
On it and you know.
And you know.
Like this is not like the first time.
There's been like an arc server.
Like a Vtuber arc server.
But in the past I would.
I think I think you guys know.
I talked about before.
Because I know like you guys would be like.
Why didn't you join.
Like why don't you join this arc server.
Blah blah blah.
And I think I talked about before.
Where the reason why I never joined.
The like arc servers in the past.
Is because.
Of language barriers.
And because like you know.
I didn't.
I felt like I wouldn't enjoy it.
As much due to the language barriers.
Going in.
And I wouldn't.
Because like the whole thing about it.
Is like being able to communicate.
With other people.
On the server.
Like I mean if.
You know if I can't speak the language.
Like I feel like it wouldn't be as fun.
Especially when like you know.
The majority about this is like the role play.
And like I don't want to force people.
To speak English.
You know.
So like at least like in this one.
I can understand Chinese.
So I can like at least like speak.
Sort of speak it.
I can like understand and listen.
To it.
So like at least I can like contribute.
At least.
At least I can like contribute.
To the conversation.
That's why I said yes.
To.
I said yes to like joining.
To joining the server.
So I'm really excited.
Huge shout out to Hiro.
For giving me an invite.
To the server.
What else?
I think that's really it.
In regards to.
I mean I wrote some stuff down.
Like what do I want to update.
My chat with.
Let's see.
I like how I'm looking at my server.
My discord server.
Where I write like notes and stuff.
And all of it is just like tech notes.
Down L2.
Forward forward 2.
Go for grab instead of instant heat smash.
Drawing heat.
Do tomahawk instead of instant heat.
Running 3.
Then R3.
Like I'm just.
My server is just like notes of stuff to do.
And fucking tech.
Forward 3 route running.
Down back 2 3.
.
Technically.
But like next week is so exciting.
I oh my god.
Next week is going to be so fun.
I cannot wait for next week.
I wish I could just fast forward.
I'm super nervous about WrestleTuber.
I am really really nervous.
No spoilers.
You'll see you'll know.
You'll know when you see the schedule guys.
No spoilers.
You'll know when you see the schedule.
But next week is going to be.
Well for me.
For me, I'm gonna be having fun.
Like...
For me, it's gonna be a good time.
I'm not gonna overhype it.
I'm just saying, I'm gonna have a good time.
Just gotta wait in anticipation.
Also, I noticed people were like, is the Anime North panel gonna be streamed?
No, it's an in-person event.
So like, you have to be there.
Well, I'll be digitally.
I'll be there digitally because I'm not real.
But like, you have to be at Anime North to go to that panel.
This is my first time doing a solo panel.
I've never done a solo panel before.
Apparently, there's gonna be a moderator there, so I can talk to...
What's it called?
A mediator?
Fuck, I don't know what it's called.
The person that tries to make sure everything goes well.
Um...
Um... and like...
I'm not sure yet if you can give me gifts yet.
I should have asked.
I think you can.
Media... yeah, it's a mediator.
Yeah.
So I think you can give me gifts and stuff, and then they'll ship it over.
Um... but like, let me... I need to make sure... I need to ask confirmation.
I won't be accepting anything like...
I won't be accepting... obviously, food.
I will not be accepting food.
I will not be accepting like...
um... electronics.
I will not be like...
like...
I will not be accepting electronics.
I will not be accepting like... um...
I don't think I'll be accepting like... um...
I guess like retail plushies.
I guess if it's like handmade or something.
Like...
I don't know.
I don't know what the rules are.
But like, if we are accepting gifts, um...
um... those are like my personal rules.
Just to make sure, like you know...
Will you accept real cash?
No, because the post office is gonna steal it.
Like...
This is why we don't send... you know back in the day?
Before PayPal was a thing?
People would literally send cash.
You guys remember that, right?
Like back... okay, no.
Some of you guys are way too young.
But back in the day, people would actually like...
um... put cash in their envelopes because PayPal wasn't a thing yet.
Which I... it always surprises me that fucking Elon Musk owns PayPal.
Anyway, great choice.
Thank you for the file.
Get the chips.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
And her name is John Doe King.
Do-do-do-do.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um... sending cash might be... No, it's not.
People used to put actual real dollar... real dollar bills in like envelopes and just send it over.
And then like um... the post office would uh...
Oh, he doesn't own PayPal anymore?
Didn't he used to?
He got... okay.
Yeah, that seems like something that would happen.
He was... when did he get kicked out?
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, remember!
Cause he wanted to call it X.
I remember now.
He tried to call like PayPal X.
And then PayPal was like bro.
That's I remembered.
Yeah, cause people were like bro this is not the first time he tried to rename a fucking website to X.
It's not stupid.
Yeah!
I remember now.
That's why I knew that I didn't want to.
Oh my gosh, it's so fun.
What a fun fact chat.
Um...
Um, friend!
Thank you for the akasupa!
Thank you, thank you.
Do you still accept supers?
Of course I do!
What the fuck?
Thank you!
I like money.
Okay, like.
You can't be like, wow, dokey, uh, shameless much.
I like money.
You can't fucking judge me.
All of you like money.
It's like saying if you like breathing.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I hate money.
Oh, you hate money?
Oh man.
If only there was a way to give away that money that you hate so much to somebody that likes money.
What can... what guys...
What do you think... what kind of solutions can we offer to that one person that hates money so much?
If only there was such a simple, easy way with just two presses of buttons that would send all that hate money over.
Charity.
My middle name is Charity.
It's a dokie charity bird.
Mr. Broken Pond thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
I don't like money here.
Take it.
Money!
Love it!
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Oh man.
I hate money too.
Nexy thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you Hirudoki.
I hate money, you can have mine.
Thank you the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Alex, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you guys.
I really...
Damn, so many money haters.
What a shame.
Oh my gosh.
What was I saying before?
I got so distracted.
What was I talking about before?
Before I...
The infinite money glitch.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Anime North.
But yes.
But yes, it is an in-person thing.
It's not gonna be streamed or anything.
The panel.
So you guys have to be there to see what the fuck the panel is gonna be.
I think it's just a Q&A.
It's gonna be a Q&A session.
So basically you go there, ask me questions and we hang out.
It's like a stream, but like... you're there.
It's like an exclusive stream.
Oh yeah!
It's like a member stream, but more exclusive.
I think that's like the best way I can explain it honestly.
Huh?
What?
It's true though!
It's true!
I feel like that... that's like basically what panels are.
It's just like a member stream.
But like it's a more... it's more exclusive.
Um... I remember like... oh my gosh.
I remember when like Anime North was like...
Oh hey, we're gonna have to like... um...
They were like... oh we're gonna have to like cap.
They're like... oh sorry but only like X amount of dragoons can like be in the panel room.
And I was like... that's... that's a lot.
I don't remember.
I think it was like 200.
Let me look at what they said.
I remember it and I was like... oh my god.
They're like... oh yeah I hope you're okay.
We like... if not everybody can... uh... be there.
Like can like be in the room because like it's a fire hazard.
I was like... bro that's a lot.
Let me see what I said.
And I felt so embarrassed.
Because I was just like...
Oh man like... that's... I don't know.
I don't know if like... we'll even have that many people there.
Let me see.
Uh... oh my gosh.
I wanna see like what I wrote.
Cause it's sort of a little embarrassing.
Cause like I felt... I felt so bad when I said that.
Um... let me see if I can find it.
Uh...
Oh my gosh.
Is it the same person?
Maybe this is for a different one.
Uh...
Let me see if I can find it.
Wait is this the same person?
Or was it for a different convention?
There's so many conventions guys.
There's...
Uh...
Fuck.
Okay.
I need to find it.
Let's see.
I wish I wrote... oh no I don't know where it was.
I guess this wasn't the same person.
Uh... I think it was 200.
I think it was... I don't remember.
But...
It could have been a different person I was talking to.
Um...
No it has to be Anime North.
Unless she's always an ARC.
No okay it has to be.
Uh...
But anyway they're like is it okay if like...
If like we have to like turn some dragoons.
Like we might have to like have a hard cap of how many dragoons are allowed in the room.
And I was like oh that's fine.
I don't think we're gonna fucking fill that up.
I was just...
I was just like...
I think that's fine.
I don't think we're gonna...
I don't think we're gonna fill up the room.
I was just like...
And then they're like oh we have a lot of...
And then they're...
I don't know.
I was like I don't know.
I don't know how many dragoons are gonna be in Toronto.
I don't know.
So then they're like...
Oh bro.
They're like no we had this other VTuber and we had to cap...
Hard cap it.
And we actually get like a lot of people at our convention.
I was like oh...
I'm sorry.
I was like I'm so sorry I didn't know.
I didn't know.
I don't know.
Okay to be fair in the previous panels...
I never really know how many people are actually...
I mean I could see there were a lot of people.
But like in my head I'm just like oh yeah.
Oh here we go.
Okay it's 600.
They're like the room seats 600 people.
And it's a pretty hard cap from the fire marshal.
And they're like oh and going by like...
Like the crowd will be completely full.
And I'll just be like I'll be surprised if I get 600.
I'll just be like I'll be so surprised.
I told him that.
I told him.
I was like no way.
And they're like oh we've had like a thousand plus...
They're like anyway.
And then the organizer was like okay.
We're just gonna pretend you're gonna get like a thousand plus people.
Lining up just in case.
They're like we're not gonna like not plan for this.
Because I was like oh I think it'll be fine.
I was like no I think I don't think you have to worry.
Like about the line.
And they're like and then the organizer was like...
We're just gonna assume that we'll be prepared for like if a lot of people line up.
And they're like...
They're like Doki this convention has 37,000 people attending every year.
And I was just like oh that's a lot.
That's a lot of people.
That is a lot of people.
So yeah I mean I'll still be surprised.
I really I will be very surprised.
Because like I'm just one person.
That's why I was like...
I was like I'm just one person.
So like I don't know if we get 600 people.
I'll be very surprised.
But I'll really appreciate it.
I really appreciate it if you guys actually fill up the room.
It'll be a blast.
We're gonna party.
We're gonna have so much fun.
Yeah.
Anime North is the first...
Is the first convention in the Doki World Tour.
Yippee!
Yeah!
I'm sorry that we couldn't do a meet and greet.
Because like Anime North was like super last minute.
I think.
Because we saw the email from Anime North very late.
So like we couldn't...
At that time they were like full on like guests and stuff.
But they slid me in last minute.
And because of that we were able to...
We were able to like have a panel.
Because it was like the only thing that was like free.
I guess.
They didn't have enough time to actually set up any meet and greets and stuff like that.
Only because they're like...
It was like a last minute slip in for me.
But I'm happy to still be able to do like you know...
Do a panel at that convention.
I know guys you're like World Tour.
There's a lot of Canadian...
Look guys!
I've never had a chance to do a Canadian convention.
Before.
And like you know as a Canadian...
As a Canadian...
A VTuber...
Like come on.
Let me have this.
The American goons had almost all the conventions guys.
Let the Canadians have one.
Not one but like maybe several.
Also.
Another update.
Um.
Yes.
I've been getting a lot of emails regarding shipments of the debut merch.
I'm really sorry that it's been taking a while.
Um.
We were uh...
Like negotiations with the distributor is taking surprisingly longer than I expected.
Um.
So like currently the only orders that are going out at the moment are the orders that I've personally packaged.
And I think I've packaged like 200 orders myself.
So like there's a lot of da- There's a lot of orders.
So I'm really sorry.
I'm gonna post it to Twitter.
I'm gonna post it on Twitter update at the moment.
Uh.
So.
Like I- I won't be shy about like how many.
I'll let you guys know.
There has been 6,000 plus merch orders.
Not just from debut but like for the Lunar New Year as well.
Uh.
But the moment we get the distributor thing.
Um.
The moment we get the distributor thing.
Uh.
Finalized.
It will go out so fast.
I'm going to try to do it faster.
At the moment, I'm currently packaging it myself.
When I do have the time.
Because obviously, time is not on my side.
So, those lucky people...
Some of you have actually already received the packages.
That I have packaged myself.
But yes, that's why...
I'm sorry that the orders are going out not as fast as I would have liked.
That's why I haven't had any new merch drops.
There's been plans for new merch drops.
I've had plans done for it.
And I am holding on to a merch drop at the moment.
But I told them...
I'm not releasing any new merch.
Until we start officially...
Not by me.
But by a distributor.
Shipping these out.
Because like...
I obviously want to get that...
I want to get that...
Situated.
Before...
Before releasing anything new.
I would say...
I know I talked about this before.
But if I did have regular merch going in...
If I was releasing regular merch...
Every fucking month...
There's a new merch or anything.
Merch would have...
Basically made...
Would be like 60-70% of my income.
If I kept the merch stuff going.
Because like...
Merch is like...
It's such a huge income.
In general.
I didn't realize how big of a difference...
Merch can be.
Until I started selling my own merch.
Because like...
The amount I was making off of merch...
When I released the debut merch...
And the Lunar New Year...
Was absolutely crazy.
I was just like...
I'm not...
I'm going to be transparent.
I am making...
If I actually kept releasing new merch drops...
I can make a lot of money from it.
But I want to get situated...
First...
With the fact that I want to make sure...
That everybody is getting their merch.
Like...
And they don't wait...
It's not delayed too long.
And that's why I'm not releasing anything new.
Until...
Until all of that is like...
Fucking done.
Until we have a...
System for it.
And...
And that's why...
There's no new releases and stuff.
Like I have...
I even have graphics made for the next drop.
But like we're not releasing this...
Until like much much later.
I think like I showed it...
People in the members might have seen it...
Seen it already.
Because I did show it.
I'll show you guys what it is.
But it's basically...
Uh...
It's basically the...
I was planning on doing a merch drop...
Of the...
Of the intro.
Let me see if I can...
I'm gonna try to explain it.
Because like...
There's...
There's no naming system for my shit.
There's no naming...
Oh here it is.
Okay...
I think it's this.
Uh...
Alright.
So like this was gonna be the next...
Uh...
Merch drop.
That's gonna be like on hold.
Until...
Until everything is okay.
People in the members have already...
Seen it.
But like it was basically like stickers and buttons were gonna be...
Gotcha.
Because like there was a lot.
We have... So it would be like...
Stuff like this.
I mean the stats...
You can like... If you want to...
You can have it all and create your own fucking...
Dancing... Dancing doki...
Like stats where you could choose.
Um...
You can choose which one.
And then uh...
I think this one had... No.
What is it?
And then there was like...
There was like gotcha for the stickers.
Because there was more choices to it.
Uh... So like stickers were gotcha.
So I could just like stick my hand in and be like...
Okay well when we have distributor...
The distributor was gonna stick their hand in.
Hahahaha.
But like...
Like I said we're not releasing that until we fucking figure out...
Until like...
The distributors shit is like...
Finally situated and stuff.
The negotiations took...
Is taking much longer.
Like I said it's taking much longer than I expected.
Um...
Because like at first...
Um... I guess like the dis...
Like when we were talking...
The distributors... We were talking to multiple distributors.
They were not prepared...
For the amount of orders...
I was gonna get.
So the negotiations were taking much longer.
Because when we were telling them like...
Yeah these are like the amount of pre-orders we're getting.
They're like... Whoa!
Hahahaha.
That's a lot more than we expected.
I really appreciate it Dragoons.
For like the huge amount of support.
Uh...
For the merch in general.
And I really appreciate your patience.
Because we have been getting a lot of emails.
Because I know I did say like you know...
Like around this time things will be sent out.
And it hasn't been sent out yet.
Um...
It's just that I'll be doing a Twitter and a community post update.
For it later.
Um...
Because I've been waiting.
I've been waiting to see if we finalized the negotiations.
But obviously we haven't.
Hahahaha.
So...
I know we've been getting a lot of emails about it.
Every day about like...
Oh when is the order coming in.
But I'll...
I'm gonna keep you guys updated.
And like I'm gonna put out a Twitter update about it as well.
Um...
But yeah it's actually crazy.
Thank you guys so much.
Like honestly like if...
I just kept going with the merch drops.
Like...
I think like...
Obviously now it's not really a big...
Like not a big part of my income at the moment.
But definitely...
I think like if I...
Like...
If I like kept the rate of doing merch drops.
Um...
If I had like merch drops every other month or every month.
That could have easily been like...
60-70% of my income.
If I kept at it.
Like I'm gonna be super transparent with you guys.
That is literally...
That is like... that could be 60-70% of my income.
If I kept at it like every month or every other month.
But I decided not to.
Because ethically like morally I was like...
I need to figure out this shit first.
Um...
Are voice packs still on?
Yeah we're planning on voice packs.
Later on in the future.
Um...
I just didn't have a time.
Like we haven't hired a script...
We have had resumes for script writers and stuff.
I'm planning on hiring more people for my team as well.
Because like...
I definitely want to expand the Doki team more.
Uh...
So that we have people that are responsible.
Cause like at the moment merch design and like merch stuff is mostly from me.
Like coming up with these things.
But definitely in the future.
I'm looking to definitely have like...
Hire like...
Like a person or a team that's dedicated to like...
Designing new merch and stuff.
And not designing new...
I guess not designing new merch but like...
Figuring out the merch system.
Hahahaha.
Yeah yeah.
Cause a lot of stuff I am doing by myself.
Mostly.
Oh my god!
Also you guys wanna see the new wrestling belt?
I know like...
I gave you guys such a huge head start guys.
I know... and you're still at 18% guys.
You're still at...
Hahahaha.
I gave you guys like one hour of a head start.
And you're still at 18%.
Anyway let me show you guys the...
Um...
Oh my gosh I'm so looking forward to like...
The new belt...
The new belt looks so fucking cool.
The artist just sent me like a draft of it.
I mean this is just like the logo.
And stuff like...
Just like the logo's being done.
Uh...
But it's not like the belt itself.
But it's like the logo's and stuff.
And I think it looks really good.
Look at this.
Oh my gosh.
Also like the belt...
Uh... cause like GamerSupps is paying for it.
And the belt that they...
They chose is like...
High quality as shit.
It's like $300 belt.
Hahahaha.
I just wanna say.
Cause like it's actually like... what's the word?
Like there's like... it's like bump...
Like what's the word?
It like actually pops out.
Like...
What's that word when like...
The metal is actually popping out.
Type deal.
It's not like a printed thing.
There's like actual texture.
Um...
Is it embossed?
Is that what it's called?
Embossed?
But like the metal actually pop out.
And stuff.
It's not like a printed metal or anything.
They like chose like...
They wanted to do like the...
Um...
Um... the one where it can like...
It's not like stamped or anything.
It's actually popping out.
Um...
But it's so cool.
Like they showed me like...
Where they're ordering it from.
And it's like...
Much... like to compare...
The last belt I ordered was like $100.
Like...
The belt they wanna order is $300.
Hahahaha.
Like...
That's the...
That's the difference.
Hahahaha.
So um...
Super... uh...
Um...
I'm super duper excited.
Uh... for everything.
But yeah!
Those are like some of the updates going on.
Um...
But I am super duper excited.
Like I said I'm really...
Thank you guys again for like being patient with the...
Merch stuff.
I don't mind being transparent.
Cause I know like people are like...
Oh!
Why are you leaking out like how much you sold?
And stuff like...
I don't...
Who's gonna fucking like yell at me?
I'm literally the CEO.
Hahahaha.
Who's gonna yell at me?
I'm the boss.
Hahahaha.
Who cares if you guys know how many I sold?
Cause you know I put all my income...
Back into my own channel anyway.
Hahahaha.
Like all my income...
Goes back to my own channel anyway.
Who the fuck cares?
Like...
Hahahaha.
Oh yeah also Minecraft update.
Um...
Let's see.
Oh yeah.
I know like some of you guys are like when's the Minecraft server?
I'm so sorry it's taking so long.
We like hit some...
Bumps in the road.
Because like I was also really busy and they needed...
Like they needed me to like...
Figure out like colors...
And stuff of like how the server looks like.
So like...
Okay let me show you like a before and after.
Hahahaha.
We will redecorate this later.
Okay I know like the colors right now.
They might not be like the best.
Hahahaha.
Like...
Um...
Anyway.
So like...
Uh...
Cause like okay this was the original color for the main hub.
We're gonna change the main hub later.
Cause at first like I wanna give you guys more...
Like... Okay sorry.
For those...
For those who don't know we are starting a...
Members uh...
Dragoon Minecraft server.
But like I'll be streaming the server publicly.
Because you can't like...
You can put the server like join the server behind a paywall.
But you can't stream Minecraft behind a paywall.
Uh...
But like I know like it's been in the works.
Cause there's been like a lot of stuff going on.
But like this was the original concept for the lobby.
But I was like that's just too brown.
Hahahaha.
I was like oh my gosh.
It's just brown.
Hahahaha.
And then we're gonna also later on.
When we actually have people in the lobby.
So then we like put more color into it.
Like and so it looks like this now.
I know it looks...
Weird.
Hahahaha.
But like um...
Um...
I know there's like a lot of colors.
Uh... But like I said this is just...
A main lobby.
Uh... It is just a...
Uh... It's just a main lobby.
For now.
So like obviously you all spawn in here.
All you guys will spawn.
Like there's gonna be... You guys will all spawn in here.
So you can create better...
Like when you join your faction.
You can create like...
Uh...
You can create like better builds if you want.
And like later on the main lobby.
Will get upgraded the more...
The more we play.
Because like now they're like what do you want?
And I'm like I don't know.
Hahahaha.
They're like Doki what do you want for your main lobby?
And I'm like I don't fucking know.
I don't... I don't know.
I don't...
I don't know.
So they made this.
From like the notes I gave them.
Which was I don't know.
Hahahaha.
So...
So I really appreciate it.
From...
From like the designers.
For making this based off of my notes.
Which was no notes.
In general.
So...
Hahahaha.
So like I'm...
That's why I was like I'm fine with this for now.
Because I think like later on.
When we like figure out what we want.
I don't know.
I don't know what main hubs should look like.
Like I've been streaming for like three months.
Like what do I have?
Like I don't know.
I don't know what main hubs should look like.
Like I've been streaming for like three months.
Like what do I have?
Like...
We'll build on it more later.
Later it'll look different.
Guys I swear.
It'll look different later.
Anyway.
Anyway so you guys are like wondering.
Okay so like what do you mean by factions?
So like...
So like you can...
You have to push a button and then you're gonna be taken to this island.
Where...
You're gonna be like picked up by the...
King which faction you wanna join.
Um...
So obviously there's like...
Aegon, the Dragoon...
And stuff like that.
So you can pick your faction.
So obviously...
Uh...
The territory will not be linked to your...
You also can claim your land.
So like each person has like...
An amount of blocks they can claim.
And uh...
Like I said this is for members.
Like to join a server you have to be a member.
Uh but we'll be streaming the server on public streams.
Like the gameplay of this will be streamed.
So obviously like...
You each get to claim land.
Uh so you know...
People won't be griefing each other.
Like you know...
You leave your build.
Can we invade people's lands if they didn't claim it?
Yeah you can.
There will be like PvP zones too.
We'll have like areas where you can fight if you want to.
Um...
So...
Uh yes and then we'll have like...
Like resource areas as well.
Uh...
So that's why like...
Uh... that's like...
That's basically what it's gonna be like.
Uh...
So that's an update on the Minecraft stuff.
Anyway!
I'll give you guys an hour...
And 15 minutes of a head start.
Let me finish one task.
And win this race guys.
Like that's literally all I have to do.
I just need to finish one fucking task.
That's all.
I don't know.
I guess they're not making this much of a competition right now.
Only like...
Really?
I gave you guys an hour?
And 30 minutes?
Almost an hour and 20 minutes?
And you're only up to 22%?
Not even 25%?
This is ridiculous.
Like...
Don't let her win!
I don't know guys!
To be fair, you guys aren't even helping each other.
Um...
Because like...
You're adding more stuff to it.
Uh... in the way that like...
You're sabotaging yourself.
So like...
It really only takes...
Several dragoons To fuck over everybody.
I like just got here.
It's like, bro, there's the backfiller.
Buster the backfiller there.
He just got here and he already lost.
Alright, rigged.
Why?
Alright, you guys better remember what you fucking wrote too.
Alright, time to work guys.
No more chatting.
It's actually time to work guys.
I zazzed on for like an hour and 30 minutes in his work day.
Oh.
Usually, okay, guys, do you think it's worth the risk to listen to like Disney jazz?
You think?
We don't need to monetize.
It's a chatting stream.
Fuck it.
I know like it's lo-fi, but like I don't care.
I usually listen to Disney jazz to help work.
Okay, Disney jazz.
No.
Dude.
I just lose ad revenue.
Who cares?
It's just ad revenue.
They just fucking- Oh no, my fucking five dollars.
They can't.
Okay, alright.
If it's not- Okay, Stu- Okay.
Studio Ghibli might be a little bit more ambitious though to be fair because it's Japan, so.
Studio Ghibli Cafe Jazz.
Alright, Wakata Jazz, that's like less- Disney and Studio Ghibli?
Alright, let's play football.
Let's play football with fire.
Let's get Japan and Disney involved.
Let's fucking go.
Japan and Disney involved.
Nice.
Uh, that's- Bro, oh my god.
Is there Studio Ghibli, Nintendo, and Disney jazz?
Okay, Ghibli, Nintendo, Disney, and Jazz.
Let's put all three in there.
We might as well.
Uh.
You're right.
We gotta throw in some Nintendo.
Alright, let's see.
Alright.
I got you guys.
We're gonna put like Nintendo.
Uh.
Oh my gosh.
Let's start out with like the Animal Crossing jazz.
Is this Animal Crossing?
Yeah.
Alright, let's start it off.
Someone stop her!
Alright, we're gonna do Studio Ghibli, Nintendo, and...
Uh.
And Disney.
All in one.
Let's go.
Might as well.
I mean, we might as well commit, you know?
Like, if we're gonna go this route, we commit to it.
Uh.
Kaz Doki demonetized speedrun any% Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Nothing can stop me!
No, I think I'd rather go with the jazz first.
Actually.
There you go.
That's fine.
Bum.
Ba dum bum.
That's fine.
We'll be fine.
It's jazz!
Everybody loves jazz!
Alright, let's work.
What do I have to do?
Answer your... Okay, I have to do Discord DMs.
Ba dum ba dum bum.
Let's see.
Ba dum bum.
I'll answer my Discord DMs first.
Ba dum ba dum bum.
Ba.
Can your friends do this?
Can your friends do that?
Put on your little hat.
I don't think you guys should cheer for 25%.
I literally have to do one task, guys.
Taurus, thank you for the 10 gift ships.
Thank you.
Alright, we're going to be making a highlight video for the Sajam Slam.
So if you guys couldn't catch like, you know, three fucking vods, that's our like five plus hours each.
We will have a highlights video being made.
I don't know when it's going to be uploaded though.
I hope you guys are being productive too, chat.
Oh yeah, I need to join the Anime North Discord.
Forgot about that.
Yay!
Almost forgot to join Anime North Discord server.
Do you guys need the music to be louder?
Or is it fine?
Define productive.
Yeah, help your fellow dragoons out!
You've only completed 68%...
No, 68 out of 263.
I can move it a little bit higher.
Is it better now?
Ba dum bum.
What the fuck?
Does someone get heirloom from Apex pack?
Oh my god.
You want the dragoons to fail.
Like...
What are these fucking impossible tasks?
Someone was like, add, get heirloom from an Apex pack.
Sabotage.
So, mod delete that one.
Mod, please, please delete this.
The dragoons are paying.
I'm not deleting that because it's feasible.
Someone quick, fund that dragoon so they can get their heirloom.
I like how Din Vizel was like, do one push up.
Done.
Did one push up.
Someone give Din Vizel a medal.
He did one push up.
10 minute push up.
Oh, you guys see that?
There he is.
Get heirloom from Apex.
It showed up on the to do list guys.
It's there.
Now you know who to blame.
Boyta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so hyped for when they see you open up that Minecraft PPP server.
I waited on this for years.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Me too.
I'm really happy to be able to open that soon.
Super excited.
I'm pretty sure you guys are going to be so creative.
And like, I want to build more on this.
I want to go on to that server and maybe host like some Minecraft events in that server too for like community events too in the future.
Because I have like an actual Minecraft team that can like they work on like they the team that hired to do the server.
They've worked for like Twitch and stuff for like Minecraft, Twitch rivals.
So they're able to develop like actual like events and stuff for us in the future.
Like member events.
So like we're obviously going to build up more and more of it.
And like it's not just going to be like something I'm just going to let it die.
I'm going to make sure that we can improve it more and more.
And there's always going to be players on it too.
There's always going to be people on the server.
And it's always going to be fun.
And if like I might have I want in the future to implement a system.
Like obviously like...
If like I feel like if X amount of maybe like if more than they haven't been back to server after like you know like three to four months or something.
Their builds like the like their builds won't be protected.
So that if like you know obviously people come and go.
I think in the future I'm not sure like I'm not sure like the time frame.
I don't want to be as make it the server so that like new people can come in.
And the new people can't come in and have nowhere else to build.
So I want like in the future.
If there's like a deserted builds or stuff like that.
There's like a way to like...
What's the word?
There's a way to make sure like new players can still can join in.
And have like somewhere to build.
You meant silly and dumb Minecraft?
No because the...
Okay if it's silly yes.
But the actual Minecraft drama.
Like...
We do not want to be involved in any Minecraft drama.
In any real Minecraft drama.
That shit is off limits.
There is Minecraft.
Yes.
Just like in Smash.
Because the...
I'm sorry.
But like the Minecraft and Smash communities are predominantly chat.
And they are children.
And because of that...
It is not a fun time.
You don't...
You don't want to be near that shit.
It's because a lot of people get popular.
I'm gonna say it.
It's not really...
I don't think...
I don't think it's like a super...
Uh...
I don't think it's like a super like you know...
Hot topic...
Thing to say.
But like...
Um...
A lot of the people...
Who get popular really fast...
In Minecraft...
They've never been...
Okay.
It's so fucked up.
They've never peaked before.
So like the most intention they ever got...
Was in Minecraft.
Um...
I was playing Minecraft.
And majority of it...
Are...
Are like...
You know...
Like they're like...
Oh my god.
Look at all this attention...
That I'm getting.
Um...
Nobody ever gave me that much attention before.
Oh my god.
People actually...
And then they're like...
I have so much power.
Then they're like...
Super young as well.
They're super young.
And that's the scary part.
When someone is like...
Really young...
And have...
Like...
So much...
Attention...
And money...
Um...
And never really like had consequences.
And it gets to their head...
Real quick.
Yes.
Um...
Cause like you know...
Being like a millionaire...
At like 18...
Is...
Nothing...
Okay...
Not nothing...
But like...
Having an 18 year old millionaire...
Is scary.
Because...
An 18 year old millionaire...
Would think...
Wow...
When you give an 18 year old...
That much money...
You don't...
You don't wanna know what they're gonna spend.
I feel like that rarely ends well.
And that's the Minecraft community.
And...
And that is...
The Minecraft community.
Sometimes they're not even 18...
Sometimes they're 16...
With million...
With millions of dollars.
Um...
But yes, we don't wanna be involved in any Minecraft drama.
Oh and then the worst part...
Is that...
Even when they have that drama...
All they have to do...
Is just wait a couple of months...
And then like...
They're fine.
Haha...
I know...
But it doesn't matter.
Because...
Um...
You might say the internet will always remember.
But like...
Children don't.
Haha...
Children will never remember.
Hahaha...
Haha...
They're like...
But he funny.
Haha...
He's...
He...
He's funny though.
Haha...
Not a...
Maturity.
Haha...
Why bad when funny?
There are new...
True...
There's new children take their place.
Haha...
That's why the Minecraft community scares me.
I mean...
Like...
We can all see...
Okay...
It's not really a huge...
Like...
Not like...
Oh my god...
Doki...
You're not supposed to talk about it.
But...
Like...
Easily...
The dream...
Like...
The whole dream...
SMP or whatever...
Like...
Everybody that's part of the dream group got fucking into some sort of controversy.
And they're okay.
Like...
Haha...
They...
There's...
It doesn't matter.
It's just still okay.
Like...
Hahaha...
What happened to that?
There's so many.
I remember like...
Because like...
Gumi...
Like...
Knows about it.
Because like...
She's like...
Friends...
Um...
With like...
Within like...
The Minecraft community.
And then I got really confused.
Because like...
She was like...
Oh my god.
Did you hear about what happened to this person?
And I was like...
Who?
And then she like...
Explained it to me.
And I was like...
Who the fuck...
That looked it up.
And I was like...
One million followers.
I was like...
Oh...
This guy is important.
And then...
And then they're like...
Yeah...
There's a whole shit going on right now.
Hahaha...
And then like...
I look back...
I think like...
Recently I checked up on it.
And then like...
They're still okay.
Like...
People forgot.
Or not forgot.
But like...
Minecraft.
Hahaha...
I'm sorry...
As soon as I hear something new about Dream...
That I don't wanna hear about.
But he's still making millions of dollars.
A lot.
Like you can't even like list any...
That's what I'm saying.
The internet will like...
Okay maybe like...
Minecraft portion.
Like they'll just...
Oh my god.
There was one else...
So.
Okay I swear.
Minecraft dram...
I can't even talk about this drama.
There's like so many fucking crazy ones.
Like...
I like just read up.
That just like, uh, showed up.
There's like some fucking crazy ones.
They're actually insane.
I was like how the... how?
How the fuck?
How is that...
How did that...
How is that possible?
And then they still have...
I don't understand.
That's what I'm saying!
They'll still have a fanbase because children are like...
But he funny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey Doki, I can't watch much right now but I'm dropping by a super because it's my birthday!
I enjoy watching your streams a lot.
Continue to be amazing and have a nice day.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Lea.
Yeah!
But he funny and pretty.
True.
So true.
That man's gonna be my future husband.
He cannot do...
He can do no wrong.
It's like...
It's like the ones...
It reminds me of like...
What was it?
When like...
Like handsome murderers are on trial.
And then the women are...
And then there's like women and I guess like gay men are like...
Oh my god but he's so hot though.
I can fix him.
Apparently I don't know if you guys noticed.
But like...
There was like...
What was his name?
Umm...
Oh my god.
It's not controversial cause he's like...
I guess dead.
Wait is he?
Who was the one that had a cult?
That had like a fucking murder cult?
Was it Ted Bundy?
Okay do you know like Ted...
Was it Ted...
Yeah Ted or was it Manson?
Which one had...
Okay there were so many murder cults.
Like there were so many.
Was he?
Charles Manson.
Did you know he had like several prison wives?
Like he was in prison for murder.
You know for the murder cult.
But then like...
Several like women outside of prison...
Would send him like mail.
And then like he got married to several women.
While he was in prison.
Cause the women outside of prison...
Were like...
Although he murdered a lot of people.
But like...
He was a lot though.
Like...
Yeah you guys didn't know that?
He literally had like wives.
He had wives while in prison.
Because so many like women sent him like mail.
Like literally wrote mail to him.
As like a pen pal stuff.
Like it's not like they were in prison with him.
It was like they were outside of prison.
You know.
Regular people.
Because they were fucking like married to fucking...
Charles Manson.
Like...
I guess you're not normal anymore.
After you're trying to fucking marry Charles Manson.
The little leader of a murder cult.
Like...
Oh yeah I guess like Ted Bunny too.
Yeah sorry.
Ted Bunny and Charles Manson.
Um...
But like they literally had like wives while in...
Like not even like singular wife.
Wife?
Not even a singular wife.
It's wives.
And then like...
And like it was very public.
With all the stuff they actually did.
Like it's not like misunderstood.
Where they're like we don't know if he actually did.
We all knew.
We all fucking knew what they did.
Like...
It's not like they're like...
But did he...
No he did do it.
We all knew he did do it.
There is an unbelievable amount of evidence.
That they did what they did.
And even after everybody knew.
What they fucking did.
Uh...
They still had multiple prison wives.
And they were like...
I don't know.
Oh yeah.
Even Dahlmer.
Oh yeah I remember that.
And his fangirls.
They don't like...
I can fix him.
People make mistakes.
People change.
I remember seeing...
I don't remember who it was.
It might have been Ted Bundy.
Like serial killers.
And like...
He was like...
Diagnosed as a sociopath.
Like literally committing several murders.
And then...
An interviewer was doing an interview on him.
And people were like...
Oh man he just seems misunderstood.
Cause you know...
If you're a sociopath.
You can...
Pretend you have empathy.
And stuff.
And uh...
They're like...
Oh yeah...
I didn't really mean to do that.
You know?
I was reading the YouTube comments.
And people were like...
And then some guy...
Others were like...
Oh it's psychopath.
Sorry.
No sociopaths are also similar.
Isn't it?
I forgot.
Um...
No.
Yeah no.
Okay psycho.
I feel like psycho...
They're not the same thing.
I'm trying to remember the difference between a sociopath and a psychopath.
Um...
Oh sorry.
Psychopath.
Yeah.
No.
A psychopath is the one where you actually have no empathy.
Sociopaths are where you can have empathy.
But it's like not really...
Not that much.
It's psychopaths that are like...
Actual no empathy at all.
Um...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That interview would not have survived if I had met that guy before they were arrested.
I'm trying to remember who it was.
It was like really interesting too.
Was it Ted Bundy interview?
Because it was a very...
Interesting interview.
I was like watching it.
Was it this?
Let's see.
I don't remember.
I wish I remember who it was.
Because the interview was so interesting.
Listen, Allison Maddow!
Oh my god!
I can't thank Sir Dublin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I don't know guys.
Guys, I don't know.
Guys, it might not be...
Might not be the smartest thing to do.
Alright, back to work guys.
Back to work.
Enough about the murder talk.
It's back to work time.
Ba-dum.
Ba-dum, ba-dum.
I have more messages!
That's crazy!
Oh my gosh!
Like...
I bought like...
Okay, so like...
You know how like I have...
I'm autographing stuff for merch?
So like...
I bought like four different marker...
Like autograph brands.
Like autograph marker brands.
Because I never had to like actually like...
Autograph...
Because like you know all the other autographs in the past I've done was digitally.
Where I just like do it digitally and then they just print it out.
So I've never had to like actually hand sign anything.
With like an actual autograph marker.
So like I was like...
Um...
Like...
I just remember this because I was like replying back to messages.
And...
Uh...
So I was like testing out the markers because I don't know which is a good...
I was like researching so hard.
Like I actually even read like...
I even watched like videos where they do it like...
They were like doing like...
Like autograph marker reviews and stuff.
I was just like...
I was like oh my god.
Like what is a good marker?
Yes dude!
Yes!
I had to like research because there's like...
I didn't want to get like a normal sharpie.
Like because like you know people obviously like you can just get regular sharpie.
But there's actual autograph markers.
But I needed one that was like a good brand.
And um...
And like I want the colors to pop and stuff.
So like um...
I bought like...
I think like four different fucking autograph brands.
I even had to like...
Um...
Ask my friend Saatchi too.
Like I think like last week I was like what...
What marker is like good autograph brands?
I was like...
Which one do I get?
I was so fucking...
Bruh...
Bruh I was so fucking...
I bought so many.
I bought so many brands.
Um...
Jerry thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Congratulations on your success.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
She suggested I try the...
Um...
What's it called?
The Sakura PenTouch.
I'm waiting for that right now.
I'm waiting for that to arrive.
I wish there was a pin.
I wish there was a pin feature on discord.
Because there's like some that I'm like, oh, um...
I want to reply back to it, but at a later time.
Wait, there are?
No, like, but like pin like people.
That's what I mean.
I'm not meant like messages, but like I meant...
Like I want to pin like...
Not messages, like pin the person.
That's what I want.
Yeah, I want to keep them because like Twitter recently added that too.
Which is very helpful.
Twitter added like a feature where you can pin like Twitter DMs.
But like you can't do that on...
You can't do that on this one on Discord.
Okay.
Oh my God, I did it.
I finished answering individual Discord DMs.
Alright, how many percentage did I finish with that?
Done.
Answered DMs.
And there you have it.
20%.
The moment I do one more task, I win.
We're still winning?
Well...
For now.
The second task can get done like in the next 20 minutes.
So you're fucked guys.
Quick someone DM Doki.
Why are you adding more?
Someone add do a flip.
What the fuck is get good?
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wmercy, thank you for the super chat.
Now that the unread DMs are answered, how many DMs have been left unread this month?
I'll never tell.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Okay.
Ba-bum.
Sorry.
There's... Oh my god.
I wish I can show you guys this.
You guys... Oh, you guys are gonna see it later.
Later.
You guys will see it one day.
But I got shown something really fucking funny.
For my next secret project.
One day.
By the time I show this, you'll know why I thought it was so funny.
Oh my god.
Fuck it.
I'm gonna...
Okay.
It's just so funny.
I have to show...
I need you guys to see this.
I just love this guy.
I just love looking at this.
Alright.
There's like no...
You have zero context as to what this is for.
But it's just so funny.
I have to show it.
It's just so funny.
I love it.
I... There's zero context.
I just...
I just love this guy's expression.
You have zero context.
You just get to see this.
Why is he like that?!
There's no context for you.
Okay.
You have zero context.
You just get to see this.
I'll just put him here.
He's just gonna be standing here.
Fuck, okay.
Oh my god, I wish I could show you guys this now.
Sorry.
I wish I could show you guys this.
This is so fucking dumb.
Don't worry.
Soon, TM.
Soon.
I just saw something so funny.
Soon, TM.
Soon.
How the fuck did some of these things go onto your to-do list?
One just says, America, yeah.
Like, what?
The other one is like, what the fuck does potato mean?
What is the potato for?
Hello.
Well, you got it.
Someone check that off.
Technically, it's done now.
That's another task done.
Have you not walked your dog yet?
When did you put that on the to-do list?
Dogs need to pee!
Bro!
Did you just add it?
When did you add this?
Oh, you just added.
Okay.
It's okay.
Sorry.
I'll stop judging.
You literally just added it.
Thank God.
I was going to be like, oh my God, bro.
Your dog.
Walk your dog!
You know,
I could make the list like longer to show up.
No, I think it's...
Actually, no.
It's the perfect height.
At least somebody.
Those people are Ashley.
Where the fuck?
Okay.
Flying potato wrote fucking become immortal.
These are the people that are sabotaging you.
These are the drag rooms that are fucking over the others.
Okay.
All right.
I think I'm done on this channel.
I finished another task.
All right.
Nice.
I'm ahead now.
All right, guys.
I gave you a head start too.
Like what the fuck, guys?
We're never finishing our task.
Mike, thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Double Mike's.
Mike BC and Mike Tyson.
Thank you for the gifted membership.
Thank you.
You saw that we're being sabotaged.
It's your.
Okay.
You have nothing.
I want to blame by yourself.
Not going to lie.
Like, what the fuck did I do?
I'm just doing my task.
Who wrote that?
It's your word.
Do literally.
I think like the mods gave up.
Sorry.
The singular mind gave up.
I mean, to be fair, I would give up too.
To be fair, anyone would.
There's like so much.
So many.
I started doing my own work.
They're still here.
They're just not moderating the to-do list anymore.
Like I'm surprised.
They lasted this long.
Honestly honestly, I'm just surprised.
They were able to last this long try to moderate this mess.
Of a to-do list.
This to-do list is so fucked.
We behaving?
What do you mean?
Literally, I'm... I can't...
Literally, I'm looking back and it's like, Get eaten out by... from Black Letter.
And get eaten out by Mike Tyson.
Yeah, you guys are definitely behaving.
Yeah, from Mr. Black Letter himself.
It was me like scrolling up like five minutes ago.
Someone had manual breathing.
Wait, hold on.
Don't judge Sarah Fischer.
There he is!
There!
Now he's on the stream!
There he is!
Another task completed, guys.
I think I won.
I don't think you're gonna catch up now.
It's over.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mike Tyson himself infiltrated the stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Chat, stop adding more!
I don't know, guys.
I think Doki's gonna beat us.
We don't know yet.
I may be wrong.
I'm not wrong.
Alright, guys.
We're gonna call it here.
Alright, race is over.
Because like, you know...
I don't think it was much of a competition in the end.
But yeah!
I had a great time.
Just like...
Of course not the rest of the two ways are over.
I mean like setting up stuff.
But anyway, I'm gonna call it here.
So I can grab something to eat.
But I had a great time.
Just hanging out with you guys.
Getting some work done.
It was pretty comfy.
Comfy time to chill.
I really like this widget though.
I think it's very...
Honestly, I feel like it...
I hope it was productive from you guys.
For you guys as well.
And like I hope you guys just enjoyed your time.
Just like hanging out and relaxing everybody.
And...
And I hope the widget has been quite helpful in general.
I really like seeing like you guys, you know...
Working alongside with me with the task and everything.
Don't worry guys.
I'll throw you guys a bone.
What is the command again?
Let's see.
Oh, here we go.
Guys, watch this.
Wait, actually I'm...
I'm worried I'm gonna do the wrong...
I put the wrong command.
Okay, give me a sec guys.
Give me a sec before I fucking accidentally lock everything.
Okay, guys watch this.
Oh.
Don't drive, that was the wrong...
No!!
Wait...
Oh, okay.
I figured it out.
Did I do it?
WHAT?!
YAY!
OH SHIT!
Nice.
Now none of us, nobody wins.
Now nobody wins!
No, I'll just do this.
And finish to-do list.
Done.
Finish to-do list.
Now nobody- Now I win.
YAY!
Look at that, you're still- fucking- you're still adding more stuff to to-do list!
What do you mean, Raid?
Yay!
100%!
Stop the count!
You guys are still fucking adding more stuff.
What do you mean?
You guys stop moving the goalposts.
We got things to do.
You're still adding more stuff!
What do you mean?
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's how dragoons can still win.
Stop.
Stop adding stuff!
Exclamation point.
Add.
I can't believe I'm the only one that finished the to-do list, guys.
We can't end the stream till this starts.
Well, unfortunate everybody.
Anyway guys, I had a great time.
I had a great time just- You can't even complete a task until 10 minutes later and they're still slow-pwned!
It was all rigged against you.
No matter what, Dokio, the house always wins.
Cass, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nah, nah, we won round one.
But it was nice just relaxing.
Sorry it's not a super long stream.
I think it's because I did a really long stream for Sajab Slam.
So obviously today is just more so chill.
And tomorrow there's double streams too.
So this is more so of an appetite.
Just a chill session with everybody.
A hangout session.
Like some solo hangout session with you guys.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What did you do?
I haven't finished one piece yet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, everybody.
I'm gonna head out now.
Gonna eat dinner and then get more work done.
But as always, everybody stay hydrated.
Pause to check.
Yeah, but move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.